the odds of you being killed by a
terrorist are practically zero so I say
relax and enjoy the show you have to be
a realist you have to be realistic about
terrorism certain groups of people
certain groups Muslim fundamentalist
Christian fundamentalist Jewish
fundamentalist and just plain guys from
Montana I got to continue to make life
in this country very interesting for a
long long time that's the reality angry
men in combat fatigues talking to God on
a two-way radio and muttering incoherent
slogans about freedom are eventually
going to provide us with a great deal of
entertainment especially after your
stupid [ __ ] economy collapses all
around you and the terrorists come out
of the woodwork
and you'll have anthrax in your water
supply and sarin gas in your air
conditioners there'll be chemical and
biological suitcase bombs in every city
and I say enjoy it relax enjoy the show
take a [ __ ] chance
put a little fun in your life to me
terrorism is exciting it's exciting I
think the very idea that you can set off
a bomb in the marketplace and kill
several hundred people is exciting and
stimulating and I see it as a form of
entertainment
yeah but but I also know that most
Americans are soft and frightened and
unimaginative and they don't realize
there's such a thing as dangerous fun
and they certainly don't recognize a
good show when they see one I have
always been willing to put myself at
great personal risk for the sake of
entertainment and I've always been
willing to put you at great personal
risk for the same reason as far as I'm
concerned all of this airport security
all the searches the screenings the
cameras the questions it's just one more
way of reducing your Liberty and
reminding you that they can [ __ ] with
you anytime they want as long as you put
up with it as long as you put up with it
which means of course anytime they want
because that's what Americans do now
they're always willing to trade away a
little of their freedom in exchange for
the feeling the illusion of security I'm
all tired of all this terrorists
alarming and the terrorist hatred all
this anti terrorists you know terrorists
are just people who like to murder other
people and what the [ __ ] is the big
problem seriously I think that they're
they become victimized in this country
because they have they it's those are
their religious beliefs and they have a
right to them to murder because here's
the thing what do they do that's so bad
they kill people who the [ __ ] will who
work so what what's so great about
people but they shouldn't be allowed to
murder them like I was really thinking
about that like so people die yeah
[ __ ] I don't know them
honestly don't care and if somebody well
what if somebody you knew died well that
would be sad but then there's the other
side to it which is I get to act sad and
people would be worried about me I'm
really concerned about me you know like
when you were in school did you ever
have when you were in school when you
were a kid like fantasies about your
parents dying so that you'd be really
special in school like of your parents
got killed you go to school they make an
announcement Joey's parents die today so
everybody and all the cute girls would
come up a Gore you okay and stuff like
that which would never happen they just
wanted me gone spilling out [ __ ] you you
[ __ ]
that's what wouldn't happen and that
would have even I wouldn't jerk off to
that having a better time than if I [ __ ]
them
jerking off later Kirk you girl saying
that to me after my parents died like
the brutal mist of that when it got me
out better than [ __ ] that stupid
[ __ ]
no idea where this is going
just one time racism saved my life me
and I was I was on a plane I was coming
I was coming from overseas and I don't
know how this guy got a machine gun on
the plane but he stood up man he said
everybody get on the [ __ ] ground
nobody look at my face I started
freaking out cuz he was Chinese I was
like why is he talking like that
[Applause]
we're screaming a crime I was the only
brother on the plane I thought only
brother I looked over there was one of
the black dude he's from Nigeria I
looked over them he was looking right in
my face man
he didn't say two words to me just
looking he was like
he didn't eat the talk we just was
talking about looking right back in some
white dudes on the front of planes seen
us they were like oh my god I think
those black guys are gonna try to save
us
[Applause]
we're just communicatin that we
understood the situation we were both
seeing the same thing what we understood
was simple terrorists don't take black
hostages that's true I have yet to see
one of us on the news reading a hostage
of energy they is treating us good we
are chilling this [ __ ] I like to give a
shout-out to Ray Ray a big Steve
a new car
you're not gonna see it taras and smart
ain't know what they're doing there you
know they terrorists they know what the
black people's bad bargaining chips they
called the White House hello
we have got five blood hello losing to
be relative quality girl Napolitano is a
[ __ ] right what she represents I
know it's not her she's just the
figurehead right right just doing any
agenda but see when they kill bin Laden
what they do really they just kill al
Qaeda okay they don't talk about okay in
a war no no they said look he's like
killing Hitler you killed the Nazis
right right so it's like done moving on
to the next thing
and here's where race it gets [ __ ] up
here's where our white people black
people being anti each other
yeah good because this the new
terrorists in America now they moving on
it's the crackers and the hills it's
those guys who really are fighting for
the Constitution they're fighting for
freedom they find no taxes they fighting
for everything that the Constitution
stands for yeah but the fact that I have
been raised as a black guy to believe
that those crackers in the hills have
targets of my face and it's really
they're trying to kill me when they
start coming down on them really so they
can take their guns take their rights
right right freedom I go yeah go get him
go get those [ __ ] crackers but really
those are the [ __ ] freedom
fighters yeah and that's where they move
into it that's the new agenda the
[ __ ] Timothy McVeigh guys that's what
they're doing as those guys are gonna be
blowing up buildings and this and that
but really have for those [ __ ] people
are living just in a shitty way yeah
yeah electricity no nothing backwards I
never thought of you buy a house if you
pay for it you still pay tax yeah that's
RIT don't
paid off your house go ahead don't pay
your taxes see what happens you then
don't own your house
they will take your [ __ ] house away
you're renting from the government sells
your land when you finish paying for
your house it doesn't matter you you now
are a renter again I don't know
desperate to ease public fears and
neutralize a terrorist cell responsible
for the deadliest attack in Spain or
they were neutralized the terrorist cell
it was actually gonna I guess gonna be
way more deadly but the [ __ ] dopes
accidentally blew themselves up I'm
trying to make a bomb that's the
greatest thing that can happen that's my
favorite terrorist story when they were
building it and then it [ __ ] blows up
it's such a [ __ ] up world man there's
just people on both sides that are just
out of their [ __ ] minds I don't get
it and it's okay why can't you just
[ __ ] be like me and you know battle
booze and watch sports and get excited
about things that don't matter
why do you have to have a [ __ ] cause
and get all into some invisible [ __ ]
guy that you never [ __ ] met and then
everybody around you has to die what is
it there's a tipping point in religion
and it's a combination of like you
believe too much and you got too much
[ __ ] I don't know what you know I
just do a bit about that if you have
like too much power and you get too much
into [ __ ] religion Lee it always goes
bad you started pressing other [ __ ]
people you know like when my people
really get into Jesus white people it
gets [ __ ] scary you know black people
get really into Jesus yeah it's a
[ __ ] great service killer band that's
it they're confined white people it's an
open [ __ ] field whatever the [ __ ]
they think they just they did they just
they run with it no checks and balances
that's the problem so I don't know what
goes on with these fight I don't know
what the [ __ ] I'm talking about I don't
know what goes on with these people
well the [ __ ] you convinced somebody
that their last [ __ ] move on the
planet is you're gonna walk into a to a
group of people sitting there watching a
show or eating a [ __ ] slice of pizza
and you're gonna kill all of them and
then God's gonna be like hey nice going
whoa hey buddy I want to talk to you you
know I would have done that but I could
dig did thank god you thought to do that
I don't know so anyways so good luck to
Spain I hope you eradicate those [ __ ]
right out of your [ __ ] beautiful
country anyways why do I talk world
politics well I know why cuz it makes
you guys feel smarter right hey Bill
maybe next time you bring up Spain maybe
you could [ __ ] a go [ __ ] yourself I'll
do what I want